WWDC it was today the kita was
incredible it was one of the most
action-packed fast just insane keynotes
that I've ever experienced especially
being there in person they were going
through these slides so fast but one of
the huge highlights was the Mac Pro and
I'm not gonna lie that was something
that I did not think that they were
going to announce today but they did and
it is here so right now we're in kind of
the product demo area so there's a bunch
of different stations set up and they
also announced new Pro displays there's
two different models of those but I can
see in here and talk to you guys forever
let's go check out and see some of the
things that they have for us
[Music]
okay so the showing an AR demo way cool
so this is the pro stand it comes in two
different models so you can decide if
you want to have the stand or if you
want to have the mount this thing is
absolutely just beautiful just look at
it
so it's crazy as you can SPECT this
thing out to be 28 course I mean for
comparison my iMac pro is 18 cores so I
can't even fathom the speed of this
thing it's so amazing right now we're
doing a custom AR experience that is
built around the macro
no way good and tap on the rim
[Music]
so what I love about this is
everything's modular so it's future
proofing so if you need to upgrade down
the line this makes it so simple here's
the built-in speakers this is such a
cool experience what I love about this
really shows you how modular it is like
everything is built to be expanded Oh
1.5 terabytes of memory sign me up I'm
gonna have to sell my house in my car
it really looks beautiful one of the
things I love so much about this is it
is expandable and I think that's one of
the things that was so difficult with
the arm ax and the iMac pros all of
those lines it was so difficult to
update where is this everything is
modular so right now we're in the
editing workflow room and this is
amazing so right now we have over here
one of the robotic cameras and they're
taking this footage sending it over here
compositing it and then we have over
here another workflow to go into the
editing and then over here you've got
your coloring station and then this is
really great they have a Mac Mini
cluster server over here this is so
overwhelming this is my dream office in
this room right now
so I know I'm not the best at coloring
but this right here is some motivation
and inspiration
there's so many incredible workflow
rooms in here let's go check out a few
more today was so overwhelming I mean we
went from place to place we saw so many
incredible things I hope you guys
enjoyed it there'll be more videos
coming soon with some more detailed
stuff talking about WTC but that's it
for now I'll see you guys later
I gotta go edit now
[Music]